[Musique] la
balle se déplace à plus de 4 000 pieds par
seconde quatre fois plus vite que la vitesse
du son l'effet de cette vitesse est
absolu vous cessez simplement d'exister donc je
vais vous entraîner
vous devez vous souvenir d'une chose amour il n'y a
pas de place là-dedans  la vie semble que tu dois
regarder ça c'est Alice elle a des
informations sur l'agence qu'ils vont
tuer pour garder le secret c'est Deveraux je sais
qu'il t'a formé
mais s'il est avec elle qu'il est contre
nous mais il appelle pour déterminer si tu as
un problème avec  l'appel je fais ce qu'on me
dit de faire monsieur parlez-moi de votre cible les
hommes
âgés avaient des compétences
vous faites ressortir le meilleur de moi ce gamin est
le meilleur assassin que j'ai jamais formé l'
un des meilleurs amis du groupe tous
tes amis essaient de te tuer heureusement
nous avions l'habitude de t'appeler l'homme de novembre
après que tu aies traversé rien ne vit